bon des boss qui est attendu en terme de
vrais troubles on devrait avoir 5 à 7 %
de jeunes qui ont le trouble de déficit
de l'attention qui pourraient bénéficier
d'une médication mais là on est au delà
de 60 7% là on arrive chez les ans à
partir de l'âge de 10 ans les
statistiques sont sorties autour de 15%
c'est beaucoup trop on vient d'entendre
un extrait à d'autres vues de docteur
benoît varin guerre ne vaut un
psychologue spécialiste du tdah
à la suite de la publication cette
semaine de la lettre ouverte de médecins
pédiatres qui lancé un débat concernant
les diagnostics également la médication
pour le trouble du déficit de
l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité
c'est l'objet de la chronique science
avec renault menu guerra a gagné bonjour
bonjour on ne relance pas le débat ce
matin on revient aux bases en fait
concernant ce conseil de ces quatre
lettres
le cdh oui effectivement on ne connaît
pas encore tous les rouages du tdah les
enfantin vont pas tous être affectés par
ce problème de la même façon et eurent
beaucoup de recherches en cours pour
vraiment comprendre comment progresse
tous les types en même temps c'est pas
uniquement qu'un trouble de comportement
c'est un problème et c'est un trouble
biologique qui souvent transmis
génétiquement qui fortement influencer
par l'environnement de l'enfant
et là encore il ya beaucoup d'études
encore pour vraiment comprendre toutes
les causes possibles
et comme on l'entendait dans l'extrait
en occident environ hausser les taux
auxquels on s'attend pour le tdah
chaussée entre 5 et 7%
mais au québec depuis 2005 le taux de
tva de diagnostic de tdah chez les moins
de 25 ans a doublé et là on est rendu
trois fois plus haut dans le reste du
canada et c'est ça c'est un des éléments
qui étaient dénoncées par les pédiatres
ça se souvient dans leur lettre et ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il faut établir
un véritable diagnostic et pour ça c'est
ça c'est quelque chose de très complexe
et ça demande un bon suivi médical qu'un
autre des éléments du débat de cette
semaine qu est ce qu on sait exactement
sur le trouve difficile de latence la
plupart des symptômes vont avoir une
influence sur ce qu'on appelle les
capacités exécutive du cerveau donc ce
c'est notre capacité de réagir à ce qui
se passe autour de nous dans le moment
présent à et à remplir certaines tâches
donc ça va affecter la concentration
l'attention aux détails lorgues
lisa sion et le contrôle de nos émotions
et une des explications du tdah c'est
que le cerveau à certaines difficultés
au niveau de la transmission du signal
entre les neurones les neurones elle se
plaît à communiquer les uns avec les
autres à l'aide de molécules qu'on
appelle des neurotransmetteurs et dans
le cas du tdah va y aurait moins de
neurotransmetteurs dans le cerveau
surtout ans qu'on appelle la dopamine
qui est extrêmement important à circuit
de la récompense
et si au moins dopamine dans le cerveau
va essayer de trouver un moyen d'en
avoir plus est une chose qui est en
train de sa production
c'est la nouveauté donc n'importe quel
stimulus aléatoire dans une salle de
classe un bruit dans un coin quelque
chose qui passe par la fenêtre ça vaut
vraiment capté l'attention de l'enfant
et ça va produire beaucoup de dopamine
dans son cerveau évite le savons est en
quête constante de dopamine de l'enfant
va passer comme ça d'un stimulus à
l'autre sens incapable de se concentrer
sur ses travaux scolaires et comment les
médicaments vient changer ça
concrètement il existe plusieurs types
de médicaments qui sont employés pour
traiter le tdah puisqu'on les conseils
ce qu'ils ont dans la famille qu'on
appelle les psychostimulants il y en a
deux grands groupes certains comme le
ritalin vont bloquer le mécanisme par
lequel la dopamine est éliminé du
cerveau donc ça fait que la dopamine va
durer plus longtemps et avoir plus
d'effet l'autre c'est des catégories
médicaments qu'on appelle les
amphétamines qui elles vont aller se
lier aux neurones dans le cerveau qui
produit ces dopamine et elles vont les
inciter à en produire davantage donc
dans les deux cas les médicaments vont
augmenter la quantité de dopamine dans
le cerveau
et ça ça va les amener à des niveaux
semblables à des personnes qui n'ont pas
le tdah est ce ça fera que l'enfant soit
moins dépendant stimuler
environnementaux et pourra se concentrer
sur ses travaux elle est justement vous
demandez ce que ces médicaments là
fonctionne pour tout le monde b pour les
personnes qui ont vraiment un trouble de
déficit de l'attention ces médicaments
peuvent aider à permettre à retrouver
une certaine clarté dans leur façon de
penser
mais dépendamment des cas certains vont
bénéficier d'autres moins et
l'efficacité du médicament peut changer
avec le temps donc beaucoup de choses
qui vont faire varier les résultats et
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
d'avoir un bon suivi médical et surtout
un bon diagnostic de départ et le
problème c'est que le diagnostic est
vraiment difficile à établir hors de
tout doute
et souvent il arrive qu'on confond le
tdah avec d'autres problèmes liés à
l'enfance avec l'anxiété et c'est là
qu'on en revient
à tout le débat qu'on a eu cette semaine
qu'ils étaient lancés par les médecins
pédiatres et qu'on a vu dans les médias
peu partout merci beaucoup à nous ça
fait plaisir à voir